I've always enjoyed looking around
looking in nature seeing things that are
round round me and when I was very when
it was young about nine years old or so
my brother received the chemistry set
and so of course i also wanted a
chemistry set but my parents felt that
having to chemistry sets in the family
making smells and exploding things with
a little too much and so they my parents
gave me a microscope and so what i did
was to take sort of the run off on the
sidewalk and such and i discovered
looking through the microscope these
little animals i mean they're called
rotifers and they have little discs on
the front of them and these discs rotate
and they sort of swim through the water
and you know when i saw that i told my
brother and my father and then i add
various of my school friends come and
everybody thought that this was really
great and so that was sort of the
beginning of my idea of going to need to
science so actually my family we come
from Austria and they had left when the
osteo was taken over by the germans my
family had always had a physician in
there so that each generation had been a
physician because physicians were one of
the things that you were allowed to be
in Austria even though you were Jewish
and so since nobody else was interested
in being a physician I some hours days
designated and when I was little I used
to go around and bandage chairs and such
and but it was sort of so it wasn't
clear that I wasn't going to go to med
school and go into science even though I
was very interested in understanding
things
and it was really only finally when I
started college and got no sort of more
ideas but had a very good chemistry
teacher and realized that if you wanted
to study understand biology you had to
learn chemistry and physics and that at
that point really is when I gave up the
idea of medical school and become a
scientist